[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
98,61% c'est le taux depuis que le chef
de la Coalition Québec François LEGO a
reçu de ses militants en fin de semaine
c'est un petit dixième de plus que le
résultat du chef du Parti québécois Paul
Saint-Pierre il y a quelques semaines
personne n'a parlé des promesses brisées
notamment du troisième lien personne
n'est sorti durant personne n'a voulu
affaiblir le chef lors du congrès de la
fin de semaine bonjour bon début de
semaine et bienvenue à l'émission non
seulement ça mais François Hugo en
ressort même plus fort qu'au dernier
vote de confiance en 2014 il avait
obtenu 97% à l'époque nous leur donnons
100% de notre confiance pas besoin de
vote pour ça Michel Cochet Jean-François
lisez Dimitri soudain c'est Françoise
Boivin bon début de semaine
alors écoutons monsieur le Gau quelques
secondes après avoir
vu le résultat de son vote de confiance
chaque jour quand je me lève j'essaye de
faire le mieux que je peux avec toute
mon cœur pour le bien des Québécois puis
cette étape là dans le dos que vous me
donnez aujourd'hui
ça me fait du bien merci
[Applaudissements]
alors une table dans le dos il me semble
qu'il y avait un consensus autour de la
table la semaine dernière pour dire que
son sa confiance allait baisser il me
semble que on était un peu tous non
c'est Françoise vous étiez la note
discordante c'est ça d'accord Xavier dit
quoi vous avez-vous avancé un chiffre
j'avais dit que ce serait n'importe où
dessus de 95% en fait il baisserait pas
de popularité parce que à cause de ça
son nombre de côtés puis
c'est pas une table dans le dos tu me
grattes dans le dos je te gratte dans le
dos alors une étoile dans votre cahier
Françoise vous Jean-François vous aviez
dit si je me rappelle bien c'est à peu
près sûr que ça va baisser si ça baisse
pas on a un problème ça a pas baissé ça
a monté qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on
a un problème
c'est quoi le problème c'est bizarre
c'est oui j'avais dit que
les militants lac font ce qu'ils veulent
donc je ne doute pas que c'est
effectivement ce qu'ils ont voulu
exprimer hier peut-être que on a vu dans
certaines délégations de chaudière à
palage qu'ils étaient moins nombreux
peut-être les mécontent se sont pas
présentés c'est pas une bonne idée quand
on est mécontent tous présenter aussi
mais c'est clair que on ne mesuré
l'hégémonie que François Legault exerce
sur son parti mais après avoir
renoncé à un engagement formel certains
coûte que coûte qu'il allait prendre il
y a pas eu de militants qui ont dit
quand même c'est comme on t'aime on veut
garder c'est sûr mais quand même on
n'est pas des carpettes regardez on est
des carpettes on va garder non seulement
on va garder mais on va dire qu'on
t'aime peu importe ce que tu fais OK et
moi je trouve ça un peu malsain parce
que à la fois il y a même une personne
au micro pour dire écoutez on est très
déçu puis on a hâte de voir comment vous
allez compenser la région de choisir un
palace ou un truc comme ça zéro mais
dans les corridors les journalistes je
suis sûr que vous avez tous cherché des
mécontents vous n'en avez pas trouvé un
seul pas un seul qui avait un bémol on
demandait à personne de demander la tête
de françois Hugo mais de montrer un peu
d'indépendance esprit et donc ce qui est
un peu paradoxal c'est que effectivement
c'est un score extraordinaire pour lui
c'est pas c'est pas dans des zones ou
d'autres chefs ne sont pas allés il est
juste un peu au-dessus de de
saint-pierre-près mon nom je pense que
Pauline avait eu davantage aussi mais
dans les circonstances que ça nous dit
de la CAQ c'est que ils sont pas encore
ils ont pas encore commencé à se
transformer en un parti de militant avec
l'indépendance d'esprit puis des moments
où ça brasse un petit peu où il y a une
vie démocratique forte et une sorte de
signaux on en parlera ou les militants
par exemple sur la nationalisation sur
la privatisation de la SAQ qui est une
vieille un vieux cheval de bataille des
gens de la droite ou bon ça a été battu
parce que le ministre des Finances
voulaient pas que ça soit adopté
est-ce que ça dit moi je pense que un
des bénéficiaires que ça c'est Eric
Duhem qui peut dire à ceux qui sont
d'accord avec certaines de ces positions
comme la privatisation vous voyez vous
êtes pas respecté au sein de la CAQ on
ne vous entend pas les gens qui
devraient représenter votre opinion ne
parle presque pas ce qui fait que vous
avez pu vous avez une autre maison ou
aller qui est
Eric dum et son parti conservateur je
pense que ça c'est une des conséquences
de la fin de semaine intéressant donc
derrière le chiffre il peut y avoir des
conséquences Dimitri vous voyez ça
comment le vote de confiance de Monsieur
le groupe
je vous parle souvent en expression donc
aujourd'hui je vais vous rappeler qu'en
politique on dit que la victoire à
plusieurs pairs et la défaite de
torphelines au Québec
le père s'appelle François Legault et
les orphelins c'est les quatre parties
d'opposition
écoutez il ne faut pas oublier la
réalité que François Legault a réussi
son pari là où Mario Dumont et l'Action
démocratique du Québec ont échoué
c'est-à-dire il a fondé le parti il est
le père fondateur de la CAQ il a gagné
l'élection en 2018 il a gagné une super
majorité en 2022 ce que j'ai trouvé
intéressant et lucide c'est quand vous
les journalistes vous lui avez posé la
question 2026 ce que vous allez être là
et il a dit j'ai deux conditions 1 que
les gens veulent que je
m'excuse
de Monsieur le gars
et écoutons monsieur le
je suis pas en train de réfléchir sur la
relève ce que j'ai dit puisque je répète
deux conditions pour que je sois
candidat en 2026 sentir la pluie de la
population peut être en santé
la pluie de la population est trop santé
Dimitri oui puis j'ai trouvé que sa
réponse était très honnête d'habitude
les politiciens dire oui je serai là
sans équivoque mais je dirais qu'il y a
une troisième condition
il faut que son épouse approuve une
autre élection et ça et ça c'est une
réalité donc écoutez le score de près de
100 mètres
une question
vous êtes jeune vous êtes Geneviève
Guilbaud puis vous aimeriez être chef de
la collision Québec un moment donné
quand vous entendez François Legault
dire ça vous réagissez comment
mais on reste tranquille et on s'assure
que le père fondateur nous choisissent
comme comme son poulain successeur son
dauphin mais merci merci Michel donc
essentiellement puis les scores puis je
sais Jean-François plutôt ce matin en a
parlé que que les membres de la CAQ vous
avez dit bonjour François qui sont
timides ou qui sont
[Musique]
souvenez-vous en 2000 Lucien Bouchard
avait eu 91% et après ça il a quitté
donc laxe d'un nouveau parti ils aiment
célébrer la victoire et pour ceux qui
pensent que c'est c'est bon on m'écoute
pas je m'en vais au Parti conservateur
du Québec ça va être des gens de
conviction mais des gens de conviction
qui vont se retrouver dans une réalité
dans un parti qui présentement à l'heure
actuelle n'a aucun siège à l'Assemblée
nationale donc ça fait du bien de faire
partie
d'un parc d'un parti politique qui est
au pouvoir donc pour l'instant François
Legault continue à dominer dans les
sondages au Québec et bien sûr il a le
plein contrôle de son parti partie qu'il
a fondé Michel ça vous dit quoi ce
résultat mais pourquoi il y a pourquoi
elle est un point 39% et on peut voter
pour lui
cela dit Monsieur Lego quand on quand on
le voit comme ça
dans l'extrait que vous avez souligné
tantôt quand il s'exprime sur ce ton qui
choisit des mots qui sont qui font appel
à l'émotion moi je crois sans sincérité
quand tu dis que le matin il se lève
pour faire de son mieux mais quand il
l'exprime comme ça pas juste devant ces
militants il l'exprime devant nous tous
parce que c'est très bien que ça va être
repris dans les médias il y a là il y a
là cet appel à l'émotion et les
Québécois aiment ça parce que pour les
Québécois ça démonte une certaine
sincérité c'est évident que nous assez
ici tous les jours à analyser tout ça on
n'est pas aussi enthousiaste par rapport
à ça parce que ce qui est agaçant dans
ce congrès là
plusieurs promesses brisées ou en tout
cas des résultats qui ne sont pas
atteints si je pourrais vous parler de
la maternelle 4 ans à la maison des
années le troisième lien le salaire des
élus ça va pas bien en santé ça va pas
bien en éducation puis malgré ça on
entend rien la question qu'on peut se
poser est-ce que parce que est-ce que
c'est un phénomène de société
c'est-à-dire est-ce que il y a une
espèce de même si ce sont des militants
est-ce que dans notre société une espèce
de désintérêt qui fait que par exemple
dans chacune des régions dans chacune de
ces circonscriptions là déjà en partant
il y a plus de débats il y a plus on a
moins d'intérêt écoute moi ça m'a
fasciné ce week-end parce que j'en ai
fait des congrès des conseils généraux
puis ça brassait autrement puis même
quand mon chef avait 95% de vote de
confiance
sa brassait au niveau des des résolution
puis Jean-François raison c'est pas
normal qu'on ne discute pas davantage du
monopole de la SAQ 20 ans plus tard 10
ans plus tard 15 ans plus tard parce que
c'est quelque chose qui revient c'est
comme si même sur l'énergie sur
on ne sent plus
véritablement d'engagement et de débat
et ça je trouve ça inquiétant pour la
démocratie même au sein d'un même parti
mais en même temps avez-vous vu les
ministres il y a des ministres qui ont
dit avant même du Congrès
peu importe ce que vous dites pendant le
congrès c'est nous qui avons décidé ben
c'est alors ça aussi ça c'est l'autre
constat du week-end monsieur fitzgerbin
a dit on n'est pas lié c'est vrai que le
gouvernement est relié tu es pas obligé
de le dire par respect pour les gens qui
se déplacent à Sherbrooke pour venir
débattre pas ensuite monsieur
le gars quand même quand j'ai vu en
disant Mor on est en face la discussion
et le même Éric Girard qui dit NON NON
pour sur la défiscalisation qui dit non
non sur le monopole la SAQ il dit ça
avant le congrès pour moi c'est un
manque de respect à l'égard de leur
militant et effectivement ça tue
possiblement que ça donne d'aller au
micro si de toute façon tout est décidé
d'avance alors bon alors on verra oui ça
arrive tout le temps ces choses-là mais
là je trouve que c'était
particulièrement
tranquille mais mes dociles c'est
probablement le bon mot mais il y a
autre chose que je n'arrive pas à
m'expliquer et je pense que ça voudrait
la peine que que certains fouillent ça
davantage là pour dire ben est-ce que
c'est un désintérêt
globalement dans notre société pour
débattre de ces propositions là où
est-ce que ce sont les médias qui
prennent trop de place aussi d'une
certaine façon et qui s'exprime à la
place de la population en tout cas il y
a moi j'ai un malaise par rapport à ce
genre d'exercice qui mène à pas grand
chose c'est sûr que le dissident que
celui qui était qui serait allé au micro
il aurait fait la page Journal de Québec
puis le Journal de Montréal peut-être
que les gens veulent pas se retrouver là
non j'ai vu que vous aviez levénement
mais je vais juste donner la parole à
Françoise pour qu'elle nous dise ce
qu'elle pense du vote de confiance
moi je faisais juste m'imaginer c'était
n'importe où en bas de
98.5
les titres auraient été mon Dieu
François Legault moins populaire que
Paul Saint-Pierre la Mondon ça aurait
été en pleine page même si c'était des
questions décimales alors je pense que
pour la carte c'est certainement réussi
nonobstant les les commentaires de
Jean-François je les comprends parce que
comme le disais Michel nous on analyse
on regarde la situation au quotidien il
y a des décisions qui se prennent des
décisions qui se prennent pas c'est
frustrant la langue mais nous on ne le
nez collé dessus alors que la population
est souvent les militants c'est quoi
c'est des gens qui entourent un candidat
et ici c'était des candidats qui sont
devenus députés pour la très grande
majorité alors Dimitri a raison quand tu
parles de c'est un parti de la victoire
c'est ça que c'est ce que je vois il y a
venir moi parce que ça je pouvais pas
concevoir que à peine quelques mois
après une victoire historique pour la
carte mais qu'on décide parce que les
médias le mettent à pleine page les
réseaux sociaux sont aussi des gens très
engagés sur la question politique mais
qui sont pas très représentatives je
suis allé en fait semaine au camping
puis j'ai parlé avec des gens puissent
ils savaient même pas qu'il y avait une
convention un congrès du troisième lien
qui disait on te regarde à TV c'est
assez viens pas nous Assala avec ça la
fin de semaine alors ça vous donne un
peu un éventail de la situation et ça
entraîne les réponses qu'on a entendues
ce que je donne comme point positif à la
CAQ malgré que c'est ou un coup de poing
en pleine face pour tellement de
personnes à il nous disent la réalité
les résolutions qui sont prises dans un
congrès imaginez-vous d'or ça a pas
force de loi pour un parti qui est au
pouvoir il sent pas obligé moralement
François le gosse essayer de dire ça du
bout des lèvres mais
par les ajustintes Trudeau là avec les
les
résolutions qui sont adoptées en matière
de réforme électorale même sa propre
position sur la question puis le Parti
libéral du Canada c'est quand même le
parti qui va avoir gouverné le plus
longtemps alors on est presque habitué
l'on peut s'insulter jusqu'à un certain
point mais on a reçu la réalité
directe verbalement il s'encachent pas
et aux militants à ce moment-là de
déterminer si ça fait leur affaire ou
pas puis je pense que la CAQ a décidé
que ceux qui sont pas comptables qui
voudraient aller avec Eric duel mais la
porte est là prenez-la je ne vous pas
peut-être mais
c'est une riche de chiffres ils savent
qu'ils font le plein bien plus du côté
libéral du côté centre droit que du côté
de l'extrême droite il y a beaucoup plus
de plein de d'électeurs à aller chercher
de ce côté-là alors les chiots avec Eric
duem vous avez vous allez avoir du
plaisir vous allez avoir des Congrès le
fun mais pas très productif en termes de
de concret
mais pour conclure sur ces fameuses
résolutions les membres d'un parti
politique quelconque parti politique
peut faire des suggestions en adoptant
des résolutions imaginez les manchettes
aujourd'hui Sébastien si le ministre du
Bénin et Girard aurait dit on est ouvert
à tout tout est sur la table bien sûr
que c'est résolutions de nos membres
vont être sérieusement considérés il y
en a même une qui est passée la
résolution numéro 2 qui parle d'un TGV
entre Montréal et Québec
[Musique]
imaginez encore une fois
que tu gardes silence t'es pas obligé
d'en rajouter ou laisse le dépasse
le débat se fait et après ça commence
mais soyons clairs ce n'est que des
suggestions conclusion de ce congrès
comme la vie Françoise ils ont fait le
porter puis François Legault continue à
être le roi de son parti et c'est à lui
de choisir qui sera son successeur et
quand il veut sortir Jean-François
moi je pense que c'est enfin moi je
considère que ça fait partie de mon rôle
de refuser de m'habituer à
l'évidemment démocratique des partis
politiques ça fait partie de mon rôle de
dire que c'est pas comme ça que ça
devrait fonctionner parce que ça a pour
ouvrir la vie démocratique
je pense que je vais donner un exemple
nous j'ai été aux particuliers
écois 7 ans soit comme conseillé au
ministre pendant qu'il était au pouvoir
lorsque les résolutions du Conseil
national arrivaient
on avait toute une opération pour dire
bon ben il y en a un certain nombre
là-dessus on est d'accord pas de
problème il y en a un certain nombre qui
sont
c'est compliqué ça nous complique la vie
et donc ce qu'on faisait c'est que les
ministres les ministres pas attaché
politique les ministres concernés par la
résolution discutait avec les proposeurs
pour dire qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
exactement ça on peut le faire sans on
peut pas le faire vous les vues
voulez-vous modifier votre votre
résolution dans la majorité des cas
d'abord ça leur donner un pouvoir énorme
aux militant d'avoir le ministre avec
eux qui discutaient de leur
revendications de leurs enjeux et arbres
on n'avait pas compris ça comme ça on va
faire ça ou parfois ils écoutent ça on
va le faire mais on veut pas le dire
tout de suite on va l'annoncer dans deux
semaines il retirer le résolution puis
on se retrouver avec trois ou quatre
résolutions avec quelqu'un on était
vraiment désaccord et les proposeurs
étaient vraiment ils voulaient les
amener au plancher et là on avait le
débat puis soit
on les faisait battre soit il passait
puis là on était pris avec maintenant
tout le monde voyez que on était pas lié
par toutes les résolutions mais il y
avait un réel dialogue démocratique même
quand on est au pouvoir dans
l'opposition c'est moins c'est moins
compliqué une des raisons pour
lesquelles je pense que la vie
démocratique est si atrophiée à la CAQ
c'est que les militants n'ont pas le
choix des candidats vous savez moi
j'apprécie la compagnie à venir Québec
c'est le chef sur CV qui décide de la
totalité des candidats même aux
dernières élections il n'y a pas
d'investiture alors ça ça fait partie la
vie démocratique du parti que les
militants en leur sein choisissent le
candidat parfois le centre veut imposer
un candidat mais ça se décide par la
vente de cartes si t'as pas cet aspect
de ta vie démocratique c'est sûr que tu
as approuvé l'indépendance d'esprit le
pouvoir des militants locaux puis sinon
même pas le pouvoir de décider de qui
sera leur candidat et après ça
évidemment tous les élus
savent qu'ils ne doivent leur choix
qu'au chef et les futurs candidats
savent aussi que s'ils disent quelque
chose de travail le chef les choisira
pas alors chose ça très malsain voilà
mais ça donc il exerce un contrôle sur
son parti puis on le constatait
rapidement
l'autre côté de la médaille puis il ne
faut pas oublier je sais que Ottawa
c'est un fait j'assume c'est la même
chose au Québec
ultimement même si c'est une investiture
c'est le chef du parti qui doit signer
le passé de chaque candidat dans le code
d'élection Québec donc le chef a
l'autorité
ultime de signer ou de ne pas signer
même si un candidat combien de fois il
ne faut pas oublier combien de fois et
mais l'autre l'autre l'autre côté de la
médaille c'est imaginer certains
candidats est-ce que Pierre faitgemin
serait capable de gagner une investiture
et dans plusieurs cas ça ne veut pas
dire parce que tu es capable de vendre
le plus grand nombre de simplement pour
ton investisseur que tu serais le
meilleur candidat donc je pense qu'il y
a un équilibre entre peut-être avoir des
investisseurs dans la grande majorité
des comtés mais le chef comme l'avait
fait Jean-Chrétien et et je suis du même
bord que lui doit garder son son son
pouvoir de pouvoir nommer des candidats
dans certains comtés
des fois quand tu veux équilibrer le
nombre d'hommes femmes je veux dire les
autres partis politiques là peuvent bien
pointer du doigt la CAQ mais il y a des
considérants de hommes femmes et ainsi
de suite alors il y a des jeux de
coulisses qui sont un peu partout puis
quand tu as pas de base lac avait un
champ pratiquement vide c'est-à-dire il
y avait rien il y avait rien de qui à la
cape sauf quelques compter alors dans ce
contexte là on peut peut-être pardonner
un peu plus le contrôle du candidat
quand tu as un historique comme le PQ le
Parti libéral du Québec qui ont des
chasses gardées malgré que le virement
de moins en moins c'est peut-être plus
évident de laisser le peuple parlé une
dernière question à vous Michel quand
François Legault regarde dans le
rétroviseur ok loin on avait
l'impression qu'il voyait Québec
solidaire enfin il aimait ça s'attaquer
à Québec solidaire mais en fin de
semaine à ma connaissance pas un mot sur
Québec solidaire pas un mot sur parti
libérale mais des attaques sur le Parti
québécois en attente du grand soir pour
régler tous les problèmes au Québec
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait que
monsieur Legault porte maintenant
attention beaucoup plus au PQ je pense
que les sondages le dérangent je pense
que le positionnement de Paul
Saint-Pierre de l'abondon comme la
deuxième force politique au Québec le
dérange puis moi franchement je pense
que si j'étais à sa place ça me
dérangerait aussi parce qu'il faut quand
même pas oublier son passé pecquis si
François Legault là on en parle rarement
mais il y a un vrai au sein du Parti
québécois quand même bon nombre d'années
il a été ministre de ministère important
et oups tout à coup il y a un orgueil
François Legault il y en a il y en a un
et puis je suis certaine qu'il y
aimerait pas ça et puis moi aujourd'hui
je pense pas que ça va arriver en 2026
tant que ça mais on sait jamais en
politique hein on sait jamais ce qui
peut se produire mais je crois que il y
a quelque chose qui
le chicote profondément de voir
qu'effectivement son ancien parti avec
un chef beaucoup plus jeune qui fait sa
politique autrement qui qui monte dans
les sondages qui qui est même pressenti
pour être Premier ministre dans les
sondages je pense que humainement
parlant
sale chicote écueil il veut arrêter
cette ascension là du Parti québécois
parce que les francophones des régions
nationalistes très fortement pourrait
être tenté d'aller davantage vers le PQ
même si pensait que le PQ gagnerait pas
la prochaine élection il pourrait perdre
plusieurs côtés on sait jamais on sait
jamais
à la coalition juste un tout petit mot
Jean-François vous réflexion là dessus
ouais ben ça ça me je trouvais ça
amusant dans son discours hier il y a
dit le problème avec le PQ c'est que eux
ils font rien jusqu'au grand soir alors
que nous on agit
comme François Legault était ministre du
gouvernement piqué puis il agissait tous
les jours sur toutes sortes d'affaires
est-ce qu'il est en train de nous dire
qu'il y a rien fait pendant les années
où il y a terminé si attendait le grand
soir
c'est un plaisir en plus il voulait
arriver
fortement Québec solidaire me semble
dormir sur la switch expression très Uta
Waze et puis une partie libérale ben il
est inexistant faites attention il faut
qu'on pèlerin va venir vous chicaner
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI